oui c'est un dispositif exceptionnel
dont vous ne verrez aucune image et pour
cause cet après-midi le transport de la
cour d'assises du rhône sur la scène de
crime s'est déroulé à huis clos sous
haute protection policière il ne s'agit
pas d'une reconstitution mais bel et
bien de la suite du procès alors nous
avons tout de même aperçu jurés et
magistrats arrivés en bus en début
d'après-midi sur ce parking du théâtre
de mâcon vite rejoint par un jacky
martens sous bonne escorte à l'endroit
précis où l'accusé est suspecté d'avoir
croisé la route d'anne sophie girollet
en mars 2005 alors ce groupe d'une
trentaine de personnes a pris le temps
de refaire le trajet de l'étudiante
lyonnaise de la sortie du théâtre
jusqu'au bord de saône là même où la
voiture et le corps de la victime avait
été retrouvé immergé
le parcours a duré environ deux heures
je vous propose d'écouter les avocats de
la famille giraud l'est et l'avocat de
la défense
je pense que ça permet de visualiser que
tout ça ça se passe dans un mouchoir de
poche un seul homme peut effectivement
parvenir à emmener contraindre une jeune
femme à le suivre à quelque 150 mètres
de la sortie d'un spectacle pour la
brutaliser
l'emmener à sa mort il a ajouté un en
solo nous sommes sur le lieu des faits
des années après plus de quinze ans
après il est très difficile d'avoir une
idée précise de la manière dont dans ce
crime a été commis
on écoute tout de suite patrick gironnet
le père de la victime de moins en moins
confiants quant à d'éventuels aveux de
l'accusé l'électrochoc il aurait déjà dû
l'avoir lors de la reconstitution il
aurait déjà dû l'avoir
lorsqu'on lui a posé des questions sur
sa présence ici sur toutes les preuves
qui s'accable contre lui donc je
m'attends pas un électrochoc
non le délibéré est attendu mercredi à
lyon nous verrons alors si la journée
d'aujourd'hui a permis d'éclairer les
jurés sur les circonstances de ce crime
pour lequel jacky martens bien que
confondu par son adn continue de clamer
son innocence